hello and welcome to this video which
has the wrong number not anymore
you are playing euros lie here with
black euros slave and now g3 and Knight
f3 are the main continuations after this
I get to play my ship c5 system the
improved capo system as it seems to be
coined nowadays the cop of system is
playing Bishop c5 with knight on c6 and
f6 so with this move in and improved
caliph means that you don't have to play
Knight f6 and actually can benefit from
having the knight back on g8 the
flexibility so you can play age 5 in
some cases you can play with 97 in some
cases ya here h5 would be possible but
I'm I don't like it so much to play the
move if White has not Castle yet after
castling h5 is definitely good but if
white plays with a three rook be one
whatever other slowish moves on the
Queen side and it feels that it feels
that h5 is a bit premature and nothing
like unplayable but I feel it's um it's
a better choice to to just cancel and
play in a more solid Wayne yeah yeah um
in this kind of scenario was the move b5
is often interesting I mean currently
not completely certain if I should do
that or not Bishop t2 Oh what does he
want to do probably and he wants to play
b5 himself maybe
it's not a big deal in itself I can play
98 for example and then c6 but this is
an interesting interesting idea like
let's do it and see how this unfolds I
mean taking on b5 now looks odd as I can
take d5 so that's not going to happen
and I'm not sure what he's doing now you
can something like a look to see one on
Queen to c2 something like that looks
fairly normal
okay this I did not have on the radar at
all it gives away a pawn so at least as
far as I can see maybe he gets it back
on like if I take him take t5 take
before I'm winning a pawn so I don't
know maybe he didn't think about that
I'm I don't know or is there
compensation I really don't believe it
that there is enough compensation
one one reason why I don't quite believe
it is that I probably get to play a five
and Bishop c5 and that gives me a very
sturdy structure and then I go c6
finally to make the pawn count so you
know looks good
okay night I want to copy ships
five maybe maybe this is a good move to
play just cover
yeah of course is a good move him I'm
covering eform
and I might even be able to play a phone
please give me a great square on d3
hooray yes the square but does it really
your opponent proposes a check back I've
got a knight situate and if he wouldn't
have if it wouldn't have suggested a
take back I I wouldn't have seen it I
really wouldn't have seen it yeah I know
I don't mind to take back so much
and now this one I do understand that
you could argue take-backs
you don't think but don't give take
backs and so on but I rather want the
game should be yeah to continue in a way
because it is so interesting to see how
to convert this like 96-95
let's call them
and that was a prophetically a mouse
lebay I wanted to play a Queenie one who
wanted to play Queenie - okay so
Knight is excellent only five I mean
that is the that's an excellent square
bling hmm I don't know what are you
doing that I mean okay maybe you've held
it was spoiled anyway due to the which
is a take back but then don't request it
yeah anyhow um the the line where you
can play with age five or where it is
definitely good is this one or something
that I had on the board multiple times
also on video but white delayed
canceling with playing a three and in
this position you can still play aged
five as you can see it's one of the top
choices of the engine but I don't feel
it is as much justified as it is when
you have the King on g1 and 97 this is
this very normal development scheme it's
very okay for black I mean not better
for black or anything but you have a
position where there is a fair amount of
non symmetrical in it so you have
chances to do something it's not dull
and but it is still very classically
founded well-founded and solid it's
nothing completely wacky or so yeah okay
ninety-five Queen d7 is totally normal
Bishop d2 I was a bit surprised about
I've felt like usually that belongs on
to be to Wow
I don't know Queen b3 or a couple of
moves possible but okay that it's not a
mistake cannot be yeah I know when I
went b5 which is certainly yeah kind of
debatable it's may be its main virtue is
maybe to put some oil into the fire
and see what happens that same fuel to
the fire that write in English I don't
know
yeah okay now play day four and
therefore I think it's just not working
and it's just just a pawn for not much
so yeah he should keep the tension in
some way as I mentioned I expected it
moves like Luke to see one yeah and then
I'm not entirely certain what I do
maybe Luke FC eight or something along
these lines
ultimately I want to play Bishop age
three which at the moment is not really
working se seven is hanging so something
like that looks very very normal and
then the engine suggests that e to c3
yeah on this one to have Bishop h3
Bishop age one I guess it's a
complicated position I mean b5 is really
debatable because you're in some way
playing on the side of the board where
your weaker button as mentioned one
quality is sided at some yeah add some
sharpness to the position okay guys
thanks a lot for oh yeah basically I'm
or do we have to check something here I
think this looks very very
straightforward I get get the bone and
now here the stability Knight to g6
three five is four it's awful
it's really awful yeah thanks a lot for
watching